if russia does invade ukraine it could
drive gas prices even higher the price
of oil is already above 90 a barrel the
highest it's been since 2014.
errol barnett is following this in
washington errol good
morning hey there michelle good morning
you know typically we see gas prices dip
at this time of year when it's colder
people are spending more time at home
and less time on the roads but 2022 is
different take a look at this
aaa says that the national average price
for a gallon of gas has climbed to 3.49
in the past week that's 19 cents more
than a month ago and nearly a dollar
more than a year ago now the main cause
of this recent jump is the high cost of
crude oil according to the u.s energy
information administration more than
half of the cost of gas that we pay is
dependent on the price of oil and russia
produces more than one-tenth of the
world's oil supply so of course any
military action by russia in ukraine
could send the price of oil well over
100 dollars per barrel but here's an
important detail the us does not it's
not a major importer of russian oil but
certainly if the global market value of
a barrel jumps we're talking about a
domino effect here that will eventually
be felt at american gas pumps so
certainly what happens overseas tony
could definitely hit you in your wallet
yeah it's a big interconnected world
errol thank you very much